ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show
so much to cover this week as many of
you know i have been
banned from airbnb i am no longer
allowed to conduct
business using the app air
b i cannot rent property using airbnb i
cannot
uh take a property to market
with airbnb i received a notification
from airbnb uh that said and we will
read it for you right now
uh that i believe that i was in
violation of uh
one of their safety practices
uh all stemming from an event where i
rented a property in joshua tree
and um you didn't delete it did you
i probably did i think i i did delete it
check your instagram i deleted it there
too
it's a tough week uh on social media to
be pushing buttons
this is not the week on social media to
be
uh testing the waters as they say
big tech is ready to paint with a broad
brush
they are ready so i might put something
up for a minute and then it might be
gone and you might go why is he doing
that
why is he being a [ __ ] i'm being a
[ __ ] so that we can all have nice
things
for a while and we want to have an
instagram page
we want a twitter account we want all of
these things for as long as we can have
them we would like them
thank you so sometimes you have to put
something up for a minute and go you see
and then yank it and get it out of there
so that's what i had to do
unfortunately these are the times we're
living in
but let's go through the facts here
because the fa and i don't want any harm
to come to these two women
i don't like that they are liars
i don't like people that
misrepresent the facts and do so
in a way that i cannot defend myself
because there was no process on airbnb
for me to do that
they just unilaterally removed me
from their service and this is
unfortunate because for the inauguration
i wanted to rent
a bunch of houses in washington dc
because a lot of my friends
wanted to go down there and congratulate
joe biden
and we were trying to get up a bunch of
homes down there in the surrounding area
in what was what some of my friends were
calling the blast
zone
but they just wanted these they wanted
to get in
and i so that's sad right
amazing but we rented an airbnb and
joshua
it was very expensive but we got a good
deal on it
see so much out there people speculate
as to what's really going on they don't
have any of the facts and i understand
that's what they have to do right
but airbnbs if you book them a few hours
uh before uh they stop accepting
bookings for that
period you usually get a good deal so we
got this airbnb for less than half
of what it was okay uh
i went in there with ben with ray and
with lucy
ray's girlfriend we were there one night
to just they had never seen the desert
they're simple people i just wanted to
show them the desert
uh we found an airbnb that i thought was
pretty cool
um i had contacted the hosts
uh they were very aggressive at getting
me in there they said well we're getting
another offer for tonight which was a
lie
they were lying they needed the money
they need the money uh
this is the reality uh we stayed there
we made a meal
we've covered that at nauseum if you
want you can go back to the last episode
and go through
what we cooked um and we left dishes in
the sink
that's all we did and now on joe rogan
by the way when yonas pop this one on
joe rogan joe rogan's like
who i love but is like kind of saying
well you should have cleaned the dishes
because that
what what's that what's that about
that's not punk rock
first of all you pay a 400 cleaning fee
which i assumed was for cleaning
you see that's why i paid the fee
all you had to do was wash dishes a four
hundred dollars should should
should really give me license to like
[ __ ] up the whole house
not permanently but i should be able to
have pillow fights and throw comforters
off beds and
it's four hundred dollars for the and
then there's like well it's really for
covid cleaning okay
it's like yeah we know that's scam it
should cover cleaning and cleaning it's
the same cleaning by the way
you're cleaning you're disinfecting
nothing's happening
in a regular cleaning in a covered clay
what are you doing so i had
i had paid that money now after the
airbnb
uh transaction is over before
the different parties the renters and
the the people who've rented right
reviews they're supposed to be no
contact
there's not supposed to be contact these
two
witches one of them texted me
and said hope you had a great time our
cleaning crew
had a little bit of a stroke lol lol
uh please give us a five-star review so
we can stay on airbnb
i was gonna do that anyway because i'm
not a rat even though i wasn't in love
with the accommodations i don't
i've stayed in airbnbs that were dumps i
never ever give anyone really less than
five stars
i don't think i've ever done it truly
you can look at my airbnb i haven't
everything i give is five stars i never
want to [ __ ] up anyone's business with
my own
whatever let people figure it out the
way i figured out this place was a dump
i don't know you anything out there i
don't like that's why i hate all this
crowd sourced
you know reviewing and yelp and this
that and the other things
it did none of it i don't trust you on
you i don't trust the masses i don't
trust the public
to give something five stars and then i
walk in and go oh this sucks
you know what else is the public made
popular that sucked
everything so i don't trust them so i
just say
five stars keep going on with your
business let somebody else figure out
that this place is a dump the way i did
or care so i give them a five star
review
they trash me they trash me so i was a
bad guest
and then they started lying they said i
broke their stools they have these
modern stools with concrete slabs
i put some of these photos up on
instagram these are before i deleted
them
these are not this is not furniture that
you can even
break because it's not furniture number
one these are art pieces
scattered throughout a house it's more
of a gallery than a house
they said that i broke a cactus when we
walked in the cactus was all falling all
over the floor
how do you break a cactus what do you
think i'm doing taking
the cactus with the spikes and snapping
it while my hands bleed
you dumb [ __ ] what do you even imagine
i am doing
how do you even break a cactus what do
you think i'm doing trying to sit on it
maybe that was it maybe i thought it was
one of your chairs
so they're lying about what happened
they're saying i destroyed their
property
then i texted them because i was upset
i was not i was upset and i texted them
that i texted them
that i that kind of that was going to
burn their house down
i said i i hope nothing happens to your
property which was
that but i do hope that nothing happens
i was being nice to my saying i hope
nothing happens
and then she said are you threatening me
and then i said we'll see what happens
because i'm not threatening you but
we'll see what happens
and then i sent her a gif or a gif how
they call with the simpsons house
burning you know the simpsons house
burns
this is all good fun we're having fun
i'm a
joker and we're having a good time and
these women probably reported this to
airbnb
and they got me kicked off of airbnb
these two women um they broke
a contract a social contract that i had
with them they asked me to do something
i didn't
okay i did not ask them to give me a
high rating maybe i should have
but they gave me a not only a low rating
they trashed me and lied about what
happened
and now i'm no longer allowed to use um
airbnb
i'm not i don't have any dealings with
these women i don't care about these
women
jonah and mila uh i i just those are
your names you trashed me on a public
forum
so i came on my podcast which is
listened to by by by
hundreds of thousands of people and and
some of them maybe i don't know what
happened
i don't know what happened maybe they
sent you a few little messages
having a good time what you did was you
dishonest
and wrong and you're hurting my ability
to conduct business
and i have to speak publicly about this
because i have a platform it's not my
fault
that you two don't have a platform you
know what i mean maybe spend less time
eating each other's [ __ ]
uh drinking uh out of your tea
collection and
passionately supporting elizabeth warren
i don't know what you're doing
but all i'm trying to say is this you
can't get me from being homophobic
because i'm also
gay so i'm allowed to hate you for who
you are
not because you're lesbians i don't care
about lesbians i hate you for who you
are you're insufferable
pseudo-intellectuals pretend designers
you are not architects you are not
designers you are less than nothing
you've you've put together a house that
is grotesque it is laughable
it is self-parity okay what you've done
it is truly embarrassing you should have
a [ __ ] like me walk through it
and let you people know how wrong you
are about every design choice
you've made in your home and is an
uncomfortable sterile
doctor's office like environment that is
only
fit for weird sexless dykes to sit
around
and [ __ ] drink chamomile tea and talk
about how much they want to munch
elizabeth warren's box
that's all that house is for and i'm
sorry that i came in there
with love and light and i infused your
home with a little character
and i'm sorry that you are [ __ ] on
me now i can't use airbnb
but but that's it we're leaving it here
that's it we're just gonna leave it here
will people rent the house and will i go
back in it yes will i do a live podcast
from it absolutely
can you legally do anything about that
probably not i can go as a guest
and do a live podcast from your home and
i probably will i don't know when it's
not gonna be soon it'll be when you
think this is all forgotten
and i'll just upload photos of myself
[ __ ] on your toilet
because as long as you keep renting out
your house
people are gonna find their way in it
honey
so again that's all i'm saying here and
that's my little
disclaimer i want no harm to come to
these women or their business
i am the bigger person literally and
figuratively
they look like weird [ __ ] i don't
know
but i've just had enough she then texted
me do you want me to get the
review removed she was probably trying
to do some wheeler dealer [ __ ]
no no no no no so now i can't use airbnb
airbnb is d-platform me okay and some
people are rejoicing in that
that's fine uh i can clearly
use other people's airbnbs use vrbo
become set up a fake account being a
fake person
listen what we'll figure it out none of
it matters to me anyway
but i just wanted to clear the air there
and and just kind of bring people up to
speed that were maybe confused as to why
is he putting his stuff on instagram and
taking it down because there are people
out there
that now are trying my ability to defend
myself publicly
is is unfortunate now now people are
trying to take that ability away from me
so i just want to relax for a minute
because these social media tech
companies
have gotten rid of the president of the
united states they will clearly
get rid of tim dillon a young patriot
who is just trying to conduct business
uh appropriately
so that is my two cents about that
that's what i have to say about the
airbnb
don't harass these women don't pay them
any mind
if you rent their home invite me i will
come we'll do a podcast from their home
that's all and
again nothing we won't destroy it we'll
actually document how lovely
uh we're treating it while we live
stream
uh from their house but the these are
people who are
detestable uh people uh because of the
way they've acted
and uh i made a joke to them over
a text message about burning down their
as a joke
i was sending first of all i'm sending
the the gif for the simpsons
house burning because wildfires are a
problem
in california it's true it is a huge
problem so for me to not tell them
that that's a concern for them
is crazy so
these are women that just don't know how
to have friends and all i'm trying to be
is their friend speaking of friends i
was out the other night this
is a new thing now when people i was
edit i was at
a socially distanced backyard in los
angeles which we all know was burning
down with covered we all know that
and they're it covet is real disclaimer
it's real it can be devastating it's
[ __ ] up several people i know
those are all true things and and
and as apparently everyone in los
angeles has coveted even if you don't
have any symptoms and you've if you've
tested negative recovery you still
probably have covered right that is the
message from the government
if you don't have symptoms and you've
tested negative uh you're not out of the
woods
so by the way that's fun for the anxiety
hopefully nobody has anxiety
one in three la residents have been
infected by coronavirus it's a new
estimate
it's a nielsen rating right we think
this amount of people are watching
jersey shore
we don't know but if you have anxiety
this has been great
how's in the last year been nicer
remember when we all cared about mental
health
all of a sudden that went out the window
when the media every other day is going
are you do you feel good guess what did
you test negative
guess what you got it [ __ ]
it's real and it sucks but here's the
other thing this is a little a message
for the people that have survived it
because
i've had enough i really have had enough
now with i was in a yard yesterday
two people in the yard had had covert
they hijacked
the entire event which was not really an
event it was just
a hang they hijacked it
to discuss how they both
beat coven how bad it was and how no one
in the history of the world
will ever understand the struggles that
they went through
not aids not cancer not those
[ __ ] with als nobody will understand
how hard it is to beat code i go i
haven't
had it i said i've been being relatively
careful i said i got
very sick in march i had all of the
symptoms i tightness to the chest
i had chills i woke up in the middle of
the night i couldn't really leave the
bed i was exhausted i could make it from
my bed to my couch maybe i lost smell i
don't really know but i know that my
taste was all [ __ ] up
i could barely eat it took me three and
a half weeks to get my
things back and then they look at you
and they go no
you didn't have it you would know if you
had it this doesn't even feel
organic it's a bio weapon that you do
battle with and they're literally
doing like cobra kind moves in the yard
about how covered they're like
you think you're good then it hits you
from the side and then you double over
and then you have to kick
and you have to hit you again and i'm
like what and then i'm like well other
people get really sick
you know my friend's mother had
pancreatic cancer she fought that for 10
years and they're like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i had covered you don't
understand it's a bio weapon
they act like they defeated the chinese
military with this
you can't even get a word in edgewise
with these people you can't say that
other people get sick
people die of cancer is cancer not a
thing anymore
what about aids with these [ __ ]
people
lesions all over how about ebola i mean
these
[ __ ] [ __ ] will go to africa people
bleeding out of their eyes there's
lepers on the thing and they go if you
don't know about coven
i couldn't taste my hot dog you don't
know about
covid it's just a bio weapon ebola is
just one of those
cute diseases that comes from the nature
it's not a
weapon i beat a weapon so it just gets a
little
it gets a little frustrating
what is that it from frustrating is
doesn't it sound better as
frustrating i do like that it's quicker
this whole thing we know how bad
covenant is we know how much it [ __ ]
people up i've had
friends tell me how how how bad
it has been for them both physically and
mentally i understand
that dan carney for example my opener
who's had it is now
occasionally tired so i get
i get it i get it i don't know why i
haven't had it
they're saying people that smoke are
getting it less frequently it's true
this is wild man if if the only thing
that cured culverd was
butts cigarettes i mean what a [ __ ]
i'm finding that 45 people are less less
likely to be current smokers
hospitalized coveted patients were 45
less likely to become smokers the
science is not
here on this i'm not trying to peddle
junk science because then we're going to
be kicked off youtube
and and everything else all i'm saying
is this these are curious findings we
don't know i don't know why i haven't
gotten it
i'm not trying to get it i'm not saying
that i'm super human or anything i don't
have any
i'm taking the vitamins that joe rogan
tells me to take but every now and then
he calls me and he goes
you know what cures covered freshly
fallen snow and maple syrup but i'm like
i don't think so
but i'll do it right because he's
healthier than me and i trust him so
it is what it is he gets info from
doctors and different types of people
and people that are kind of doctors and
kind of are doctors a little um and i
respect joe so
anything tells me to do i listen to him
the point is i don't know why i haven't
gotten this but here's what i will tell
you
i know that it's really bad and vicious
when people get it in a bad and vicious
way
but is one of the symptoms that you have
to discuss it for seven months
afterwards is there any let up here
because truly when you bring up any
other disease
they look at you like you don't get it
and i'm like well what about als where
you get diagnosed and you literally
become a puddle and then die within two
years they go
think i'm not still no not a bio weapon
they go you don't get they go you don't
get it
this is made in a lab and i beat it
and then they tell you they're like this
is how i beat it i sat in a room and i
just went i'm gonna beat it
i'm gonna beat it i'm gonna beat it and
they're like you don't even understand
the what you go through the mental
fitness you have to ha
and i'm like yeah okay but again my
friend's mother
fought a death sentence pancreatic
cancer for 10 years
it's unheard of the woman was out doing
marches she was raising money
there are people that overcome horrible
conditions
there are people born with horrible
conditions okay
okay so this idea that the only thing in
the world
did anyone the the the mark of a man is
that he beat covert
the mark of a man the mark of a soldier
they're acting and i know it's bad
but the way that they're talking and
acting makes me feel so much
less sympathetic for them because it's
getting obnoxious
it's obnoxious to tell a group of people
that somehow they're less than
because they didn't beat what they're
calling a chinese bio weapon these are
the people by the way that have had it
they're like china tried to take hong
kong with this bio weapon
i beat it but it's tough again my
friend's mother has brain cancer she
doesn't know
she walks in the wall she can't see
anything she's losing her sight in one
eye
[Music]
this is like nothing it's ever been
i'm like okay but what about i just keep
throwing out diseases how about
leprosy lee schmannus go to the symptoms
of leprosy please
see if we can get the symptoms of
leprosy up can we get
leprosy please because this is the stuff
i was bringing up
growths around the skin thick stiff or
dry
skin ulcers on the sores of feet
swelling or lumps on the face or
earlobes
loss of eyebrows or eyelashes discolored
patches of skin
usually flat that may be numb or look
faded
you know that ain't fun
right yeah it's very painful yeah pain
areas in the joints
blisters loss of color rashes ulcers
redness reduced sensation of touch pins
and needles loss of temperature
sensation nerve injury or weight loss
how about alex get als up that's a walk
in the park
apparently because you're uh covered
let's get als up
muscle cramps tight and stiff muscles
slur to nasal speech
difficulty chewing or swallowing which
which
ends up no chewing or swallowing okay
literally what it does is it immobilizes
you oh and
it's insane how bad it is okay
difficulty swallowing drooling lack of
restraint mild cognitive impairment
severe constipation
unintentional weight loss shortness of
breath difficulty raising your foot
so you bring this up to these people and
they go dude
you don't even get it you don't even
[ __ ] get it dude this is like lab
made it's something
else something different it's just
annoying it's just annoying and it's
gotta stop
i know it's bad but it's gotta stop
life is a pandora's box of
horror okay people have
all kinds of problems some people's
problems are greater than others
some people have to go through horrible
things
okay i understand that this can be an
insane life-changing event for people it
could be a horrible thing it could kill
them it could kill me
i've been open and honest about that but
what we don't want to do is
annoy people to death as well
by pretending that you are the only
thing that matters and that the things
that you've gone through
are the only things that anyone should
ever take seriously
that everybody else in this country
that's suffering because we have an
opioid epidemic or because their jobs
have evaporated
or because they don't have health
insurance okay or that they
work all week for [ __ ] wages and nobody
cares about them
and they have to [ __ ] navigate this
world without any help from anybody
those people should all shut the [ __ ] up
because you hadn't
got sick that is not the way to to
interface with the world people do not
want to tolerate that
they just do not like that so what you
have to do is you have to have some
perspective
and see things with proportion and i
know this is a bad disease and i know
it's affected people
people have died families have been
ruined and i'm not making light of any
of that what i'm saying is please
if you've gotten through it confide in
some close friends about how tough it
was
but otherwise shut the [ __ ] up because
there are people that are dropping dead
every [ __ ] day that have diseases
that make this look like a walk in the
[ __ ] park
there's people that have brain tumors
that are like
you can't even [ __ ] operate
inoperable
brain tumors that destroy their entire
lives
people hear every day you got to get
your affairs in order
so let's just put a pin in it
for a minute when you're in a yard with
people and they're trying to relate to
you i'm trying to relate to you i'm
trying to go
yeah man i was a little sick in march
like no no no you know you know with all
due respect
with all due respect you don't
understand what this is
i fought the chinese i fought the
chinese in one
your your friend's mother with the
pancreatic cancer that's a walking let's
be honest that's a walk in the park
okay it's a walk in the park hey last
wheelchair can't move
stop stop
i had covered okay
i don't want to hear about your
hemorrhagic fever your ebola
boo
when i was a young boy one of my
favorite things to do was eat cereal
with my best friends
um many of my friends came from homes
where their parents let them eat sugar
cereals this was
uh one of the big benefits of sleeping
over their houses is you could wake up
and eat lucky charms
or you know cool stuff my mother
used to make me eat like health cereal
this is true
and that's why i became a gay cocaine
addict
so you might want to think that
rethink that out maybe let the kid have
the corn pops
and then he doesn't turn around and
start blowing people
in a in the in a you know in a library
anyway magic spoon cereal has zero grams
of sugar 11 grams of protein and three
net carbs of
each serving okay so many of you how
want that sugar cereal flavor
and now you can get it without the
actual sugar it tastes amazing it's too
good to be true
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb and gmo free
okay i love the fruity flavor it tastes
exactly like fruit loops
magicspoon.com tim dillon to grab a
variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code tim
dillon at checkout to save five dollars
off your order it's a great way to
support the show
support your immune health which is very
important right now during covet
it reduces inflammation you don't have a
lot of sugar in your system
this is better it's magicspoon.com tim
dillon
use the code tim dillon t-i-m-d-i-l-o-n
to save five dollars off
we thank magic spoon for sponsoring the
podcast
sleep is so important right now for your
immune system because of coven
sleep helix sleep has a quiz that takes
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress
is for you everybody's unique and helix
knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
size folks what does that mean
for bigger people you're telling me
there are people that are so fat they
can't fit in an actual mattress
i mean this is a little absurd helix
plus
for plus size you can't
a king doesn't work how sad are you like
you're hanging off a king
how big are you that a king-sized
mattress won't do it
what helix quiz is that what helix
quizzes that they're like are you
over 1100 pounds you're like i
am they're like hi we've uh taken the
results of your helix quiz imagine that
how insulting is that
helix has tabulated the results of your
quiz and they believe that uh
you cannot sleep on a regular mattress
you need a plus
mattress it's going to take up a
warehouse
helix plus mattresses are delivered with
a succession of trucks
and then put together outside you have
to sleep outside
i do love helix it's awesome but don't
take my word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall matches pick of 2020 by gq and
wired what really is good about helix is
it customizes
your sleep experience a short quiz you
know whether you sleep on your back side
stomach you move around all night long
you know exactly how you sleep helix
will figure it out for you they have a
10 year warranty
you can get it and try it out for 100
nights risk-free they even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will
everyone that has a helix mattress loves
it you have it right ben i love it
helixsleep.com tim dillon i have one too
they're great i have in my guest room i
got a tempur-pedic in my room and he
looks at the guest room sometimes i'll
sleep in the guest room it's so good
uh take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you the best
sleep of your life helix is offering up
to 200
off all mattresses and two free pillows
for our listeners and pillows are
expensive
legit so you get two free pillows which
is all you need and 200
off all mattresses at helixsleep.com
dillon do it right now helix sleep.com
slash tim dillon
i'm just saying you know and by the way
smokers in jersey are getting the covet
vaccine which is odd because they're
saying they've identified it as a high
risk it almost seems the other way that
somehow they're
yeah but maybe if you get it as a smoker
it's a quicker descent i don't know but
you can now get vaccinated smokers and
jersey are eligible for vaccine no proof
needed
new jersey is one of only two states
that has included smoking among the
high-risk medical conditions
that make me can i just get on a plane
and get the vacs with the butt
hanging out of my mouth they opened the
floodgates of vaccine eligibility on
thursday to about 4.5 million additional
residents
those 65 and older younger people with
underlying health problems including
cancer but i mean
we all know cancer [ __ ] that uh
heart conditions and diabetes diseases
that can lead to severe
complications with covet as part of the
explanation new jersey also became
only the second state in the country to
open
vaccinations to another high-risk group
smokers
wow you don't have to document an
underlying health condition just say i'm
a smoker what's the other state to do
that can you find the other state
yeah let's see what it is they're saying
one of them's jersey i'm wondering if
one of them's closer i could just roll
up with the butt
and how do they prove your smoke you
just roll up smoking ciggies i go here
look at my uh
podcast on youtube you see i'm smoking
cigarettes
states play smoking new jersey and
mississippi dude we gotta go get
vaccinated in mississippi
they're doing vaccines at a buffet we
gotta go down and eat some hush puppies
and some fried shrimp
and get vaccinated while smoking butts
would there be anything more american
than getting vaccinated in mississippi
while smoking a pack of cigs
and taking down a few hush puppies and
some a basket of fried shrimp
can you imagine that like nobody else
has been vaccinated yet and you're just
like
i'm staying safe they just give you the
vaccine
instead of teachers [ __ ] these teachers
and nurses let me get the vaccine so i
could go to this shakies pizza parlor
this pizza buffet so this is very
interesting
um i don't know the the t or caa called
me they're like we can get you into tier
three
because you travel tier three yeah or
tears you know well because i travel and
there's like
i you know because i travel for a job
and i'm gonna need to have a vaccine to
go
around and do my job i mean that whether
i love it or not and i don't love it and
i've been very open about my concerns
about it at the end of the day i'm gonna
have a choice between
probably doing my job traveling and
leaving this country to do my job and
doing it
all around the country or getting this
vaccine probably going to have to
eventually get it that's what it seems
like i don't
know uh ben's wife got it she's fine
yeah she felt weird though yeah no
listen it's gonna make you feel weird
you know
but this apparently in jersey you could
just kind of show up smoking bots and
you get the vaccine
yeah you have to be a resident of jersey
so i can't i mean california is such a
goddamn mess
god only knows how they're going to dole
out the vaccine here i mean god only
knows
how they're going to [ __ ] that up i mean
california tears will make no sense
they'll just be like all right first
we're giving it to tick tockers
second surfers you know
third people with an eye twitch which
would be me i have an eye twitch
so i don't know how they're gonna
rationalize who gets it when and where
they get it
a lot of people don't want it i don't
love it but at the end of the day
i don't think i'll be able to get on a
plane to go do comedy in london
or you know australia or any of these
places
um without this vaccine this is what i'm
imagining i don't know
supposedly they're coming up with an
immunity passport these are things that
are being bandied about and i do want to
leave my [ __ ] home eventually
i mean it is time is that in the next
few months i think eventually after all
these
you know now we have the mutant strain
and there's 15 more strains and
the andromeda strain is coming i mean
it's never going to end here
but eventually people are going to need
to leave their houses because my friends
are losing their mind my friend called
me the other day because i want 250
grand cash
which i don't have she goes i want 250
grand cash she goes i want it so we can
start investing in properties together
i'm like what are you saying what are
you talking about she goes just give me
a quarter million we would start
investing in properties
crazy what are you doing me and him i
almost got taken in a lan lease scam in
new york oh yeah yeah yeah
so now here's the deal i saw this condo
in manhattan for 215
000 i love new york i'm like i'd like to
own a condo in new york
and and it would go up in value and i'm
like how bad is new york on i'm like 215
000 right from midtown manhattan what
the [ __ ] going on over there
i knew there was an exodus but christ
right how bad could it be
what are you just getting stabbed on the
way into the building 215
000 benjamin explain to them i almost
got
taken and by the way if you look at me
i am the guy they hope buys this because
when i walk into an office
this is the pitch that they make to me
this land lease
scam that ben understands even a little
better than i do
so it was a first of all very important
it was has to be cash only all up front
cash only because banks
and this is a red flag will not finance
this type of transaction
now me i'm an idiot so i see that and i
go [ __ ] cash only
they want the big rollers i'm in like
they're like they want a certain type of
p i think i even said to him i'm like
i think they want a certain type of
people i'm already putting my foot in
the door to get robbed do you see what
an idiot i am
do you see what an idiot i am because
i'm a salesman and salesman are easily
sold
if you're a salesman out there you're
easily sold yeah it's true
so the land lease is essentially the the
building does not own the land that it
sits on
so you can never technically own the
apartment it can go up at
in price at any point the the
homeowner's dues which are monthly can
double
triple quadruple doesn't matter and it
gets reassessed every five to ten years
so interestingly enough in the 60s and
70s trump plaza
made a deal with the land that the
building was on to only pay 1.9 million
for the land for over the course of 40
years and we're in the 70s yeah in the
70s wow
when that expired they owed 190 million
to own the
land because land costs in manhattan
always go up new york land costs go up
so they raise the money everyone in the
building raises everyone in the building
all the criminals living in trump plaza
raised the money because otherwise you
could lose the unit completely
because all the land gets forfeited back
to whoever owns it and you're [ __ ] but
the people in trump plaza
were able to raise 109 million 190
190 million dollars so that they were
square correct well we're not going to
be doing that over at the [ __ ]
what was this place called carnegie uh
carnegie house
yeah yeah and they they have all these
and it's on billionaires roads on 57th
street billionaires row
and i'm an idiot because i'm like i'm
telling ben i'm like you see
uh i said a lot of people are just not
on zillow trying to get these deals but
i'm on it because i'm smart
that's the great article right there
which one is it right there the 99
oh thousand dollar one bedrooms on
billionaire's route yeah this was it
carnegie's
yeah hundred thousand dollar studios and
billionaires real highly desirable
apartments if people are racing to
unload
why and then they explain to you yeah in
the case of carnegie house it turns out
it's straight forward it's a land lease
building meaning the building doesn't
own the ground beneath its foundation
the arrangement is fairly rare there are
only 100 land lease buildings in the
city and means
that the building's owners have to pay
rent to the developers which in a co-op
building of course means that the
shareholding residents
who pay ground rent in addition to their
typical monthly maintenance fees
real estate tax and any operational cost
so if the ground lease expires and is
renewed at a much higher
rate the monthlies can double or triple
land leases can reset as often as every
5 10 15 years
as the building and the property
underneath is reappraised when they do
so this is what is
uh i almost got robbed because i'm an
idiot now they would have explained this
to me but i'm such a [ __ ]
that i was actually looking at this is
like a good investment
and i'm the type of guy that they dream
of because when i walk in
to the real estate thing and i go listen
i found a good deal i know how this
works
i pay attention i got my ear to the
ground 2 15
you know i'll go in there or maybe we do
a cash deal you know
who knows like they look at me and they
go um
right they go okay so you know it's a
land lease and that means that you know
like
whatever in a couple of years they reset
the month these they can go up but
anything can go up right
they go hey 15 years 20 years who cares
right they go this guy get him another
steak
get him another steak you want a light
light up his cigarette get a mistake he
doesn't care about what happens in 20
years
you don't care what happens in five
years it doesn't matter you're happy
in the moment buy it you're a big dog
you're living on billionaires row
lie about how much it cost i mean
there's so many ways to try to sucker
me into that deal thank god ben was here
and smart and able to see i just said
white power didn't mean to i just went
like this i was trying to make a point
but this is white power now this is
screenshot that yeah they will
screenshot that and they'll see how i
was trying to do white power
all my enemies of which there's like two
enemies i have that write about me
that make like eight thousand dollars a
year to write about my podcast
every day it's like great the truth the
true threat to america
the tim dillon show
the alt-right podcast that
has never ever talked about anything
remotely all right
um it's amazing but again it must be so
comforting to just live in a reality
that bears no resemblance to the one on
this planet
and that's what many people have been
doing and they've made louis gomez a
political figure
they've made louis gomez into like a
divisive
uh political agitator and hey man
whatever works whatever makes you that
9 000 a year that you earn
writing about comedy as if it's the most
important thing when we all know that
it's
pretty unimportant um
anna from red scare was very interesting
i want to get her on the show but she
made a great point about me too and that
like the unquestioning nature of me too
not that there wasn't a lot of real [ __ ]
happening clearly but the unquestioning
nature of it
was really like lays the groundwork for
this sort of like
social compliance that everybody like
the highest
virtue in america will just be
compliance
people going yes that person is bad
this person is good whatever the body
politic whatever like
you know whatever feelings and thoughts
and ideas and opinions we all may have
we're going to subjugate them and we're
always going to take instructions
from this tech media industrial
complex now that will feed us our
beliefs
they will feed us our thoughts and we
will we will regurgitate them
because we all live in fear of being on
the outside of that
mainstream acceptable uh and that's
now obviously the other side of that is
like let's not storm the capital with
horns
and let's not you know uh you know burn
down
uh federal courthouses in portland or
seattle
um but the
intellectual response to all of this has
been pretty frightening
the people whose job is to think have
shut their minds off
pretty terrifying and they've they've
they've fallen on both sides of a binary
and everything they do just reinforces
that binary to the point where the only
thing that will happen is some type of
violent clash
there is no other option when nuanced
people like me the purveyors of nuance
in a funny way
are attacked people don't like it they
get angry
when you're nuanced but if you fall on
either side of a binary they actually
like you
left kind of loves the right and the
right kind of loves the left
because they give each other oxygen and
a reason to exist they give each other
an enemy
when somebody comes in the middle and
goes hey i'm kind of nuanced and i'm not
like a total loser
even though i did just almost get
[ __ ] built in a landline scam in new
york
pretty [ __ ] easily off zillow i am an
idiot
but you know i'm not a complete loser
and i have a little nuanced point of
view
i become the threat the threat becomes
are you [ __ ] up the binary the powers
that be loved the binary
and the people on either sides of the
binary love it so when you [ __ ] it up a
little bit
yeah i agree with them but then i also
agree with them and maybe we shouldn't
do this but maybe we shouldn't also do
that
people go oh [ __ ] you actually are
putting out putting a way forward of
like this could be a new way to think
about things
you're the real problem you know but i
haven't had coven
so i haven't really gone through the
necessary
things another thing to talk about last
night
is uh teslas everyone that gets a tesla
uh thinks they're part of the
development team at spacex
i've never seen a product like this
where you buy the product and you become
also a spokesman for the product
it's not enough that you own a tesla
everyone around you needs to know about
the tesla
what it can do what elon musk is up to
what the starlink satellite system is
it's a [ __ ]
car yes it's electric maybe it's the
future but who gives a [ __ ]
why are you going and ruining my night
never shutting up the cyber trucks
coming out and you know what that no one
no
shut up it's a 37 000
car okay a public school teacher could
afford it
it's not impressive it is what it is
it's just a [ __ ] car
i get it you drive an iphone around it's
it's got all the bells and whistles it's
it's you know it's self-driving it's so
i like driving
all these idiots are like well you don't
even have to drive you're gonna stood in
your car
and what are you doing what are you
doing
working on a hedge fund drive you have
nothing else to do
well you could self-drive yeah we know
why you drunk
we know what you want to do you drug
addict yeah you could self-drive so you
could cut lines of coke on a [ __ ] cd
case or whatever
or whatever you have yeah that's you
know that's a reference from a long time
ago but
i bet those people still have those
[ __ ] i used to do it on a gym blossom
cd
but that's my point i don't have
problems with tesla owners but everybody
thinks that they start talking about
elon musk and they start talking about
the stock fright
the stock price you think i ever bought
a car and i'm like well
ford is actually up because of you're
not
part of that you own a car
you're not part of the thing it's
really frustrating when people with
tesla's
don't understand that you're just buying
a [ __ ] car this it's a weird cult
that you need to convert everybody else
into
everybody needs to know how cool teslas
are like what you know so as somebody i
know
has when they just look at me they're
like they're the future like very
seriously
they're the future it's like hey why
don't you shut up
about the future okay it's a cool
electric car
other companies will come out with cars
that compete with tesla jags doing it
ford's doing it a lot of people will do
it
teslas will still probably be always
maybe the coolest or not
i don't know but elon musk is a little
annoying and i'm sick of him doing his
starling satellites i don't even know
what the [ __ ] they do
but they make me think it's a ufo i
think the planet's being invaded and
we're all going to get colonized and
raped and i get so excited
and then when i find out it's just this
[ __ ] goofing off
i get upset so if you own a tesla
congrats but please just pipe down it
becomes like the covet thing you're like
you don't understand yeah i i
i unders no i know it's you know the cu
the car drives it set you put on
self-driving it drives itself
and soon in a year it'll have full self
driving
why even get in the car why doesn't the
car just go to [ __ ]
ralph's for you why doesn't the car [ __ ]
your wife
why do you have to even be in the car
why doesn't the car go to the meeting
and say the [ __ ] things you're gonna
say well
it drives itself i just sit in it i'm
just a passenger
okay we get it we understand that it's
fascinating
and and great and and and i'm happy
about everyone that owns a tesla i'm
very happy about it and i'm not
[ __ ] on them i have a nice car i
don't talk about it because it's boring
no one cares about cars i don't care
about cars
i have a nice car it's a decent car it's
a fine car there's better cars than mine
there's cooler cars than mine it is what
it is
it's not a big deal okay my car is also
not mine's a gas guzzling truck
so it's not cool i don't get to talk
about the charger
think about the tesla charger all the
time and where's the well there's gonna
there actually could have supercharged
stations where if you pull up your
chargers
i hope you start getting shot in the
head at the supercharged
tesla station why don't we start doing
that why don't people start shooting
people in the head
and taking their money outside the
supercharge just an idea
wink free idea i'm just a little sick of
it i'm not i'm not hating on the tesla
people
i was in rogan's tesla it's very cool it
goes very fast well the ludicrous mode
is very fast i understand that but where
are you going
where are you going you don't have
anywhere to go you're going fast
to what what exactly are you doing are
you in a chase
are you using that car to chase down a
man who was just throwing a girl into a
van
is that why you need ludicrous mode so
you can go so fast
and then find that van and then [ __ ]
beat that guy up and then free that girl
is that what you're doing or are you
going to
like i don't know [ __ ] dairy queen
you know i mean it's like enough for any
i'm just a little sick do you understand
my frustration with these people of
course
it's a weird brainwashed cult of people
well but it's people that just want to
talk about
you you have a tesla you want to talk
about that yeah yeah you have a tesla
and all you talk about is your tesla
that's not true but that's not i wasn't
really going at you i was going a lot of
people because he has a tesla
that's a weird call to people giannis
has one michael has one yeah yeah
my friend michael has they just they
just they go you never you'll never go
back
what does that mean i'm already looking
at the lucid air it's a better ev it's
coming out in like two years you know
there's other things
this whole thing is like you'll go back
it's like yo you go black you never go
back
it's like maybe that's the case but with
tesla
i mean let's stop acting like you've
done some people that have a tesla act
like they've really
done something they act like they've
really done like they've accomplished
something
now you've accomplished something
because you used to be too drunk to even
get in a car
and now you've been sober and you're
doing all this that's great but it's
like i have a range rover who cares
right it doesn't matter i don't talk
about it because it's not interesting
the the [ __ ] british monsters that
own range rover are not trying to help
the world
by the way they like the car burns a lot
of gas
and we locked to sell it to rappers you
lock the seller to housewives
and rappers that's who drives range
rovers housewives and rappers and i'm
half of each
and and that's who drives it but enough
with the the tesla [ __ ] like enough with
it i mean i
you you you're starting to get better
about it but you love talking beginning
i was a little annoying about it well
you just love talking to people about it
yeah
you know and it's like there's other
things you're a fascinating guy there's
other things
that you can talk about besides your car
your golf your tesla yeah whatever
but it's just you know see what i do
when i walk in a room
i i always give people sort of a
dissertation
and i i don't say like oh the cool thing
about the is that the sunroof
i don't do that i tell peop when i walk
in a room
i i tell people why they are why they
are where they are
in life and that's what i feel is nice
and i feel like it's the ultimate act of
charity to walk in a room and
look at someone and identify their
weakness and magnify it in front of
others
we're all looking for ways to save money
right everybody you know insurance is
like a black box nobody knows if they're
paying the right amount of money nobody
really knows okay
so gabby customers g-a-b-i they save a
lot of money per year on average
their home and car insurance how do they
do it how do they do it they save about
961 dollars
a year it's amazing it's an extra grand
okay
so here's how they do it they go on
gabby
okay they link their current insurance
account and in just minutes
you'll be able to see the quotes for the
exact same coverage
you currently have that's what i did
it was so fast and easy i just went on
gabby i mentioned uh
you know this is my car insurance i
linked it up then i got a bunch of
different quotes
and i called uh you know my insurance
company and i'm like what are we doing
and then i actually ended up switching
so gabby customers save a lot of money
it's almost a g
if they can't find you savings like they
did for me they'll let you know
so you can relax knowing you have the
best rate out there they'll never sell
your info
no annoying spam or robocalls you have
nothing to lose
this service is just educational unless
it saves you money
and then it's actionable information and
you can choose what to do with it
they're not selling your info there's
they're they're basically saying hey
we're confident that our our customers
save an average of this amount of money
because they're just ignorant they don't
know i was ignorant you don't know that
you're paying too much
especially because most people just get
in the habit of paying their insurance
every month
and not really you're not competing all
the time you're not going to competitors
and seeing
if if somebody can undercut your current
insurance so i'm telling you right now
it's a great thing to do you're probably
overpaying
see how much they can save you it's
totally free to check there's no
obligation go to gabi.com
tim dillon that's g-a-b-i dot-com
t-i-m-d this is
absolutely there's no commitment
required they don't spam you you're not
on an email list
the reality is they're looking to help
you save money if they can't do it
hey your part is friends gabby.com
tim dillon got to keep that hair if you
can
a lot of people i know are starting to
lose their hair in the 20s and 30s it
starts to go you notice signs of hair
loss nobody's ready to go bald
and i mean come on at the end of the day
what are you really going to do
if you go bald the reality is what you
should do is try to keep the hair you
have now prevention is key
keeps treatments typically take between
four and six months
to see results it's important to act
fast the sooner you start using keeps
the more hair you'll save
find out why keeps has more star five
star reviews than any of its competitors
okay it is great and it allows you to
keep the hair that's on your head
right now for about ten dollars a month
that's what they start the treatments
start at
limited time you can get your first
month free if this is a problem for you
or you see it becoming a problem for you
in the future
this is really really interesting a
friend of mine is using this right now
obviously i respect people so i'm not
going to say who it is uh i respect
people's privacy but
you know i got them this through the
show they're very happy about it they're
they're they're seeing already
hair loss signs stop they're not seeing
those signs of hair loss you know the
hair on the pillow they're saying the
other thing
this is important you want to get it in
you and and soon
okay um so if you're ready to take
action to prevent the hair loss go to
keeps.com
tim dillon that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
tim dillon k-e-e-p-s
com okay that's very very important i'm
telling you right now look at their
customer photos they speak for
themselves
i know friends has personally worked for
you know they have a lot of five-star
reviews they do a lot of business people
want their hair
this enables you to keep your hair you
don't have to go to hair in a can
or any of these things where you spray
hair on your head you don't have to get
a toupee or a wig
you don't have to have anxiety that
you're not gonna have hair just keep the
hair that you have right now
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
tim dillon but i am getting a little
sick of houses i'll tell you this i'm
getting a little sick of
houses we're in this house right now
which is great it's a regular house you
wouldn't look at it and go
wow it's a mansion it's not it's a
perfectly regular suburban california
house
it costs a little too much money because
california costs too much money
but i don't need more space than this
it's great the reason we got this house
was there's a large
carpeted room that has a studio and
carpet's important for what the sound
right so we found this room and most
most houses do not have
old-school carpet like this but it's an
old house it's like an
old house and the things in it you know
the the
the handles fall off the doors and the
dishwasher doesn't
work and then you call the landlords who
are sweet and you go
hey can i fix the dishwasher and think
well it's a melee dishwasher which means
that uh we need a melee technician to
come in and
otherwise it would void the warranty and
because of covered we can't get one of
the technicians in and it's been broke
for a month
and now that what happened with the
wi-fi so if there's a cord in the wall
somewhere that's
disconnected or under the house or
something we can't get anyone out here
for two weeks you know what happened my
wife
let me tell you let me tell you
something my wife came in one day and
she goes
the wi-fi doesn't work you know what i
did
you know what i did to my wife i killed
my wife
i killed my wife and i buried her in the
[ __ ] round
and i pissed on her corpse i saw him
but now they're now they're coming when
when are they coming these people
in two weeks and for anyone wondering
we're doing a hot spot off my phone
that's why we're pulling stuff up but
we don't have internet so two weeks two
weeks i mean people that are working
from home would not
die that's what i told them i said yeah
from home i'll lose my job if
what do they say they started with the
covenant coven the guy yeah
we can't get anyone out yeah it's a bio
what they tell you to go you don't
understand
you tell them we need to wi-fi cause i'm
dying i have
terminal cancer they go it doesn't
matter you don't know
it's it's it's bananas that we have to
like
we have to keep tip turning around but
now i'm looking at you know i don't i
also don't have a life to fill the
suburbs let's be very honest
he has a wife and a tesla and they have
a you know it's a life two dogs
i'm just a a a a lone ranger here
so i live in an area where everyone has
families and you know they've all have
lives and i just i'm a person
so i think my next move is going to be
like a nice apartment building
get like a one or two bedroom apartment
i want
modern like i always hated modern now i
want ultra modern i want everything to
be modern i want no problem
with the wi-fi i want a lap pool to swim
every day
i want like a fitness set because i
think after covid
which there will be an after covert i
know people are like no
there will be no people who work from
home forever how are they gonna get
their dick sucked
they're gonna get [ __ ] by meeting
people at their jobs people have not
like
you can't just run everything out of
your [ __ ] basement you're gonna have
to go back out there eventually
and um like
there's going to be i think that you
know people are going to realize in a
few years if you don't have a life to
really fill
the suburbs you know or fill your house
up with the left
like you go and you get just a nice
apartment some of these buildings are
really
high-end buildings that have everything
that you could ever want they've got
maid service
they've got all these cool things that
are kind of baked into it some of them
are furnished i i furnish this house i
don't wanna
i don't wanna do any of that some people
love having a house tinkering around
doing this doing that to me it's never
been exciting i just want to be
funny my job's difficult enough to stay
funny and
whatever stay sane that i don't want to
i don't need to like walk around the
house and be like what's wrong today
this is a fun project it's not a fun
project you know what i mean
a fun project for me is trying to figure
out you know oh you know who i know in
the business is next going to end up on
the cover of the la times
that's enough of a project i don't need
to be tinkering around with door handles
okay so that's my point
my point is that i think after this year
lease is up i'm done with these old
houses i'm done with the charm
i might be done with the suburbs and i
had in la's all suburbs but like
head into more of an area of like a
modern building with some amenities and
just kind of go into that space age
type you know i don't know blink your
eyes and the curtain goes down or
something
some of that [ __ ] is cool some of this
old [ __ ] like
charm is really what you say about
something when it's just
dated and i like dated stuff but
charm and dated go hand in hand like
this [ __ ]
just the house i'm living in was
probably the [ __ ]
20 years ago or maybe not even but
whatever it's a cool house i'm not
complaining about it there's people that
are
facing evictions and [ __ ] like that i'm
not trying to be like oh we're going oh
but it's just annoying when you when
you're living in a place that
is you know you just can't have wi-fi
can't have things because there's
problems in the walls
it's probably a bunch of brown recluse
spiders and allies of the airbnb cons
just chewing on the wires and the walls
trying to [ __ ] me up that's probably
what's going on
right now or i don't know or some or
some [ __ ] mega black widows
that are upset with me because i
suggested and by the way i'm sorry for
going woke last week on twitter
and suggesting that you not bludgeon a
cop to death with a
fire extinguisher i do realize that is
hollywood elitism and i'll try not to
exhibit that behavior again
although it's hard to get tempted you
know so many of my friends have pools
and you start to think like a hollywood
elite and i go what would a hollywood
elite
say you go hey don't attack a cop with a
fire extinguisher and bludgeon him to
death
now by the way three months ago that was
a position
that would right put me squarely at odds
with the left
now people on the right are angry with
me because
you don't have to find the tweet it's
fine it's fine it's just what it is
people on the right are angry with me
because i've suggested that
we not harm the capitol police
with uh fire extinguishers and they're
angry with me
and they're like stupid they're like
yeah well it's a revolution
[Music]
they're like everyone wants a revolution
until you until it's here it's like
what you think this is a revolution how
much of a loser are you
that you think hitting a cop in a face
with a fire extinguisher
is an actual revolution that's actually
going to happen
you've dedicated your lives and your and
and
to to following around a billionaire who
lives in a castle in
florida and you think he's fighting some
underground war to free
the children that are being eaten by
other politicians
whom he was friends with up until three
years ago
you've dedicated your entire life for
that and if i say something like that's
probably not the best huh
you go shut up you don't understand
it's just a country of cults country of
cults out there i guess i just i'm
trying to avoid the cults i'm trying to
just you know it's like a slalom
in skiing you just gotta like zip past
the cults like
zip past this zip pass q anon zip pass
rush again zip ass
chronova zip past this zip fast cover
this that that that
lockdown it's like anti-mask are you
like ooh i almost became an anti-master
and then i'm like
well that's kind of stupid some people
are saying it helps and i'm not saying
you have to have it on all the [ __ ]
time but like why am i
why is my identity becoming like telling
people not to wear a mask
what is that about like i upload a photo
the other day in santa monica i have a
mask on because it's lit it's the law
here
and i have a mask on and i just and by
the way i usually put it around my chin
so i can breathe and still suck people
off
on at on the beach but i have it in my
chin and then sometimes i put it up when
like i'm walking like an old person or
somebody who's like
gives me a look like it's me and then
people are like you're a [ __ ]
you have the [ __ ] mascot i'm like
your entire identity
has become about telling me to not put a
mask on like that's your
your entire brain that small
shriveled up brain in your head you're
funneling all the energy at just getting
mad at someone who's wearing a mask
because it's literally the
law of the place that they live and
they're trying to be considerate of
other people they're like there's no
scientific proof it works i'm like
whatever the scientific studies are
whenever we find out what the [ __ ] works
and doesn't work
it's gonna be probably years from now
and guess what it's not gonna be
because some scumbag on twitter told me
it did or didn't work
there's people that actually have
degrees that are trying to figure this
[ __ ] out
and don't spam i don't even i don't even
care but like just know that your
15 paragraph youtube comment about masks
will be lost on me
i don't love masks i hate them i hate
wearing them i feel like you can't
breathe i don't like them i get creeped
out when i see like
kids with them when they jog in school
i'm all you know i don't like i'm not
i'm the wrong one but when i go out into
public it seems like the right thing to
do to wear a mask
but again it's hollywood elitism don't
smash the cop with the thing
hollywood elitism hollywood elitism by
the way
the only down-to-earth person left in
this country is donald j trump
he's the only one that somehow he's the
only one that's somehow down to earth
and i mean it's a good run he's had four
years and big attackers
they're not acting up right and the
wall's built and everyone's happy
the kids are all freed you know there's
parades every day of
kids that were victims of human
trafficking and they're just like
walking up and down the streets
i'm not saying everything trump did was
bad but i do think it was a little bit
of a mixed bag
you know even his supporters a lot of
them that are intelligent that have
brains
but now he's like deluding his
supporters to like the real
hardcore supporters like the real
hardcore like the people the the tesla
cult it's like
you have just a cult of people that just
want to talk about how wronged
trump has been and uh you know how he's
just never had the opportunities to do
the things he didn't want to do
and you'll just never understand it's
just like covet people you know
everybody you'll never understand so
everybody now just you have to sit there
and just go yeah yeah
because they want to talk they talk at
you and you just sit there and you go
yeah
yeah my aunt donna texts me every day
that everyone has corona is dying
because that's what she wants to live in
that universe
she wants to live in a universe where
it's like
terror and fear and fear and terror
because the boomers
the boomers are need to be under attack
they need to be under attack so it's
either it's ms-13
it's called like something's coming to
take everything that they deserve
and i get it i love my antonio but it's
like this is uh not uncommon in her
generation where it's like
these are people that are in love with
fear
they love fear uh and wherever they can
get it and they're not
they don't discriminate either well they
do discriminate but they don't
discriminate about what kind of fear
they want they'll take it from anywhere
give it to him from fox news msnbc the
local bulletin
a [ __ ] something on a pizza place
wall wherever they get it they don't
care they just want to be afraid
and they want to be aggrieved i mean
people are trying to kill us
everybody's trying to kill us and
somebody out there is to blame and this
is what
this is the dynamic that they love
living in that's just what it is that's
the boomer dynamic it's just we love
fear they have they have really attached
themselves to fear they have
they have had it the easiest of maybe
any generation to have ever lived
ever and they uh still somehow
find things to complain about it's kind
of impressive
it's just damn [ __ ] impressive when
you could talk to people that all of it
for a lot of them have inherited houses
gotten great jobs uh were able to go to
colleges very cheaply
uh made it if they weren't in vietnam
they kind of skated by without any
serious military commitments
in their lives unless they were
voluntary um
yes there was boom and bust cycle in the
economy and of course they went through
periods of economic hardship but that's
everybody i mean there was nothing like
the great depression
and i don't think there was too much
like the financial crisis in 2008 i mean
the early 70s were bad in the 80s
you know parts of that sucks for
different people but the people i'm
talking about kind of skated by they
kind of did really well
uh through all of these things and again
they they either idolize trump or hate
him
he is the center of their universe in a
good or a bad way
and uh because again they want it's
either rachel maddow or tucker carlson
it is
a fear-based kind of end of life
uh we don't know what else to do we've
done it all uh all the
hippy [ __ ] never was realized any of
that stuff never really happened we all
became yuppies
and then we all bought houses in the
suburbs and then we are all now
you know huddled in these houses in the
suburbs and angry and just looking
outside the windows there are people
coming to kill us and we got to defend
our you know
so i get it but i mean it's just like
that's part of why
i like the suburbs i like living in this
house but i wonder if
i i wonder if i could live in like a
modern apartment because my goal would
be to kind of live in that modern
apartment and still keep that fear
and that anger from the suburbs and
bring it into the city
keep that fear that sense of being
aggrieved that sense of perpetual
victimhood
that sense of just churning angry
violent
nasty entitlement and bring it into this
kind of modern
communal living situation and one by one
poison everybody that lives there
one by one you know but listen folks
here's the reality you shouldn't talk if
you haven't had coven
everything's about you should just have
and if you don't have it make it up that
you had it
because i know people now that are
almost provably doing that
they're provably making up that they had
covered and they're medicating covered
with things like percocet which is not a
prescribed thing
and then they're saying things that have
nothing to do with calvin like they're
saying
yeah i had a physical fight with uh i
beat up my boyfriend uh covered
i beat up my girlfriend called hey i
threw my wife down the stairs you know
how it goes colvin
so that's where we're at now if you
haven't had calvin invent that you've
had calvin
because no one's gonna take you
seriously so as of right now i'm gonna
let everyone know
last week i beat covet i punched my
mother in the face
i robbed the bank i bought a bunch of
guns i went to the capitol
and i stormed in and i went and i put a
[ __ ]
pen and i held nancy pelosi and i held a
pen to her neck
and you know why because comment
good night